okay so
let's now move away from the unsourced
conspiracy smears against cassidy
hutchinson the january 6 committee
witness and let's look at a specific
claim that's being made about something
she said that is allegedly not true
there are now reports
that the note that was put up on the
screen during cassidy hutchinson's
testimony which she said i wrote that
that's my handwriting there is a
contradictory claim being made that that
is not her handwriting so let's evaluate
this this would be uh
this is specific and substantive so and
it's sourced so there's no issue here
with evaluating it abc news reports
trump white house attorney disputes
cassidy hutchinson's testimony about a
handwritten note
former trump white house lawyer eric
hershman is claiming that a handwritten
note regarding a potential statement for
then president donald trump to release
during the january 6th attack was
written by him during a meeting at the
white house that afternoon
not by cassidy hutchinson sources
familiar with the matter tell abc news
so what's this all about
at tuesday's january 6 committee hearing
liz cheney displayed a note
which hutchinson said i wrote that
she she saw it and she said that's my
handwriting i wrote that
sources familiar with the matter say
that eric hirschman an attorney had
previously told the committee
he wrote the note a spokesperson for
hirschmann said to abc news tuesday
night quote the handwritten note that
cassidy hutchinson testified was written
by her was in fact written by eric
hirschman on january 6 2021
all sources with direct knowledge and
law enforcement have and will confirm
that it was written by mr hirschman
at the hearing on tuesday hutchinson
testified about the note quote that's a
note that i wrote at the direction of
the chief of staff on january 6 likely
around 3 o'clock
liz cheney asked and it's written on the
chief of staff note card but that's your
handwriting ms hutchinson
and ms hutchinson said that's my
handwriting
okay
this is a specific disagreement and it
is not really subject to the squishiness
of some of the other claims well
we're willing to testify that the
claim about trump trying to grab the
wheel didn't happen well how can you
testify something didn't happen if you
okay that's sort of like squishy and
subject to some kind of interpretation
this is just like whose handwriting is
it who wrote the note
and if she didn't write the note you
know people tend to to know their own
handwriting when i look you know down
here i have all sorts of cop i have
copious notes on a legal pad i can
immediately see that this is all my
handwriting
if i saw different handwriting it would
be very evident to me people tend to be
very well acquainted with their own
handwriting she said it was her
handwriting someone else is saying no i
wrote that well let's figure it out
and if she was wrong about that we would
want to know did she deliberately lie
about that was she confused about her
own handwriting which would be weird
it would be something to figure out but
understand
that every aspect of this
is that is being used simply to attack
her by people who barely even know who
she is as an example sean hannity last
night seized on this entire handwriting
thing and he said did catherine really
write it her name's cassidy they don't
even know her name they don't care they
just want to attack bring in a
handwriting i bring in handwriting
experts and they can determine was it
hirschmann or was it the the woman from
yesterday catherine right was it
catherine who wrote it well sean it was
not catherine who wrote it because no
one named catherine is involved here
they don't even know her name but to the
extent that this is a substantive claim
is it her handwriting is it someone
else's eric hirschman says i wrote that
let's figure out who wrote it and then
let's figure out what the confusion is
no problem with that whatsoever
one of our sponsors today is bluechew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping